i'm a mom
so
that's my it's my thing my kids are all
mixed with vintage and my old oscars
these are my old oscar dress we did all
vintage and like upcycled my old stuff
zahara rocked her mom's 2014 couture
oscar gown vivienne had on sneakers
while angie sported a gold lip cuff and
color coordinated with her kids missing
from the carpet 17 year old pax
i heard your kids were shook by your
costume i mean would you want to see
your mother wearing that
i mean your mom walks in in a full
spandex gold outfit with gold hair and
you just think what do you do for a
living what are you
how do you get back in your robe
salma's plus one her fourteen-year-old
daughter valentina making a rare red
carpet appearance barley say hello
is mom cool at all for this or is it
still kind of like oh mom um she's cool
yeah she's cool
in the comics your character is a male
so you know how proud are you to
represent and have a be a strong female
character that leads this movie
oh i love it just to know that you know
in your 50s you're going to be an action
hero i mean if somebody told me this
five years ago
i would have laughed so hard and here we
are
now you have bragging rights for your
son like listen to me son i'm in a
marvel movie yeah but here's the thing
my son's nine months old doesn't matter
by the time he's old enough to recognize
his father was in a marvel movie it's
seriously retro this sad father going i
was in a marvel movie
eternals hits theaters november 5th and
reunites kit with his game of thrones
brother richard madden there in a love
triangle with jimmy chan it's a really
epic story it covers 7000 years and the
themes of it are you know
is humanity worth saving
oh what a great night hollywood was in
full effect last night so cool to be at
a big premiere you saw the movie oh i
saw the film last night
all i have to say is stick around for a
mid credit scene that's going to
blow your mind
[Music]